[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
end game class tonight i am going to be
showing you
some games some end games rather from
the norway
chess tournament currently going on you
guessed it in norway
uh of course this these are uh this is
the same tournament
from the road to 2000 lecture tonight
and
unfortunately for arientari we're going
to continue looking at his games
because he loses in really interesting
ways um
you know and that is a compliment
believe it or not but he played a very
interesting game against fabiana
carowanna
that i want to start with here tonight
so let's jump into it
uh of course ariane starts with the move
e4 but we don't care
this is not the end game this is some
sort of opening
some kind of sicilian pieces are being
traded
oh my gosh maybe if some more pieces get
traded i can start to think about the
game
and yeah this is where i am going to
claim
we can officially start talking about
the position
um so what is going on in this position
i'm calling this
the start of the end game even though
there are still three pieces on the
board
black's king is very much participating
in the position
and two rooks and a minor piece against
two rooks in a minor piece
i think is safe to call some kind of
endgame
so what's going on here who do we think
should be better well let's
try and break down the position a bit i
sort of spoiled the next move already
but of course in the position
black has some pressure down the c file
and white's main benefit in the position
is going to be this d-pawn uh this is
white's big boon here right if white can
push this pawn one more step down the
board
this bishop is going to be activated and
the pawn is going to have
some very serious threats of becoming a
queen and that's how we arrive at fabi's
next move knight c4
you know not being tempted with
capturing some pawn on a4
of course this would allow the move d6
and then
you know this king has to go somewhere
and white white is very much winning the
game after something like bishop takes
b7
so knight c4 an important idea for fabi
we see rookie 2 and then knight d6
and this is the defensive setup that
fabi has against this pawn on d5
so let's try and think deep deep deep
into the future
and talk about what's going to happen in
this game
well first and foremost uh aryan starts
with e4
and now let's put ourselves in fabi's
shoes and think about
how we can try to ever uh
win the game and first and foremost how
can we improve
our position so we the main imbalance of
the position
is number one the pawn structure and
number two this bishop
against this knight so task number one
for fabi is going to be
trying to make sure that the knight is
more powerful
than the bishop in this case so how does
fobby do that
well he starts with the move a5 which is
a very very sensible move
ariantari plays a slightly strange
looking move rook to a1 here
and with this move we should have some
idea of what
white is thinking about so
what do you think white's idea is with
rook a1 and then also
down the road how can black ever try to
improve his position
these are the questions i'm going to ask
you right off the bat chat room
see what you can see what you can find
how can black uh try to win the game
later on down the road i'm not saying
immediately
but i'm saying what ideas does black
have to sort of change the position
these are important things to think
about right
not because you're going to play these
ideas immediately but because these
you know they give you a good sense of a
general goal to work towards in the game
so we're not talking about you know a
specific line just yet
we're talking about ways to uh you know
shake up the position down the road so
simon has a great idea right for black
potentially this idea of f5 is going to
be a very
important break to keep in mind f5 would
shake loose the defender of the d5 pawn
but also give this king a path into the
game right from f6
into f5 later on if white were to
capture
of course if white doesn't capture black
is going to consider breaking down this
pawn
on e4 right so f5 is a really important
move to keep in mind for both
sides in the game right both arjun and
fabi
are going to be thinking about this move
as time goes by
bobby looking for ways to make it good
and aryan looking for ways to make sure
it never happens
or if it does happen he is well prepared
to meet it
in the meantime does white have any
similar ideas that black
should be keeping in mind right
especially with the move rook a1
especially with the move rook a1
what do we think white's evil intentions
are after we see the move rook a1 appear
on the board
some people in the chat are saying rook
a3 rook b3 and i definitely don't think
this is the idea
he could have done this idea over here
instead of coming to a1
and yeah chess king mentions a really
nice idea which is
c3 and b4 right black has this one pawn
break over here perhaps
but white has his own ideas as well
trying to break through
make use of this a pawn on a4 and push
his pawn majority
on this half of the board so definitely
that is something to look out for
so what does fobby do well first and
foremost he makes sure that the c3b4
idea
is just not going to happen right he
makes sure he prevents this so how
can we prevent this now let's get to
specific moves right we have a general
idea
of what's going on in in the position we
know that black is
potentially thinking about playing these
moves uh g6 f5 at some point
and we know that white after rook a1
especially it's considering these ideas
of c3 and b4
right so we have a good feeling for what
is going on what players are playing for
now how do we turn that into actual
moves
how do we turn it into actual moves
for black
i'll get rid of some of these arrows for
you
and yeah you guys are right a lot of
people in the chat said this move
before we finish talking about the ideas
because it is just naturally attractive
to play rook c4
pressuring both of these pawns as well
as the c pawn but the really critical
idea
is after the move c3 fabi plays the
improving move
f6 and now white tries rookie 3 to try
and get this b4
idea a little bit closer to reality
maybe b3 kicking the rook and then b4
and to make sure this never happens for
white bobby plays the move rook hc-8
so this move rook c4 wasn't just some
some sort of one move threat some simple
improving move to attack the pawns
it was with the idea of doubling on the
c file not so much to pressure the c
pawn but to use the pressure against the
c pawn to stop
white's big breakthrough idea of b3 b4
in the position so very purposeful moves
by fabi don't be deceived
by how you know natural and proving they
look they are very very purposeful
and very very very focused right
and that's what a lot of these end games
require here you can't go around
playing you know just nonchalant moves
moves that you think improve your pieces
you have to be aware of the ideas behind
them and that's why i wanted to stop at
that earlier position
and talk to you guys about what was
actually going on in the end game
white plays the move king f2 here just
to try and improve
and now favi goes for a pretty
interesting idea
so we talked about the plan of playing
f5 are there any other plans in the
position for black
that we neglected to mention
any other plans for black to consider
here
so thaddee says the move b6 now b6 is
one of those moves
that may technically improve black's
position
by you know defending this guy over here
but
i don't think this is really along the
right track right
it's sort of a nothing move right and
black can make very purposeful moves
still with the time that he has
and yeah the chat is arriving at the
right idea here but maybe not quite
for the right reasons and that move is
g5
and the chat is saying g5 to create a
password because of course white will
take
black will take and then you know the h
pawn is becoming past and i think this
is a good idea
for black this is what was actually
played in the game but of course
white is not actually forced to capture
on g5 and you have to account for this
scenario
and in fact aryantari does not capture
on g5
in the game instead aryan playing the
move bishop f3
to challenge the h5 pawn but then fabi
of course responds with
move g4 and this is the real idea behind
g5
not because fabi wanted this passer on
the king's side but to get this move g4
and this may be very counterintuitive to
people at first glance
of course in these end games we are
always told to put our pawns on the
color opposite the bishop
but rarely is life that clean the games
the end games you end up in are quite
often much messier than that where it's
very difficult to get all of your pawns
on the squares opposite the bishop and i
think fabi has an
even better scenario now so if you
examine this position
black has a very distinct weakness on
the h5 square
a weakness that can be attacked with
moves like bishop f3
or eventually you know the bishop
rerouting somewhere along this diagonal
this pawn can be attacked
very definitively so by playing g5 g4
now fabi has improved his position so
that this pawn can only be attacked
from this diagonal and this is not a
very realistic diagonal
for the white bishop to land on in
addition to that
he is very seriously hampering the white
squared the light squared bishop
it has taken away two full diagonals
from this bishop and that is even better
than having the pawns on the dark
squares why is that better well number
one the bishop has limited mobility as
i'm pointing out
and number two now this g pawn sitting
here on g3
can never be defended by the bishop
right
by putting these pawns on light squares
fabi has given both sides a weakness
h5 which could potentially be attacked
by the bishop on this diagonal
in g3 which can definitely be attacked
by the knight at a later date
but can never be defended by the bishop
and quite obviously
uh to my eyes g3 is a bigger weakness
than h5 which is why practically i would
rather have the black pieces here
objectively i think this position is
level i think the game is still
equal but practically i think it is
easier to play for black
because fabi has cemented this weakness
on g3
and sort of lessened the severity of his
own weakness
on h5 this is not going to be an easy
pawn to attack for aryantari at
all so
um what should have white done
what should white have done i think h
takes g5
is actually a good move for white black
does have these ideas
of creating a past pawn but i think
after bishop f3
if you go h4 uh king g2
and these pawns might be more weak than
they are useful i think white is going
to be able to mobilize
on the king's side with this uh king
especially able to stop these pawns
and sort of play against these pawns
more than uh they actually help black so
maybe g4 would be played anyways
and then we would get a very similar
position but one in which
the f6 pawn has been treated for the h4
pawn
is this favorable for white i actually
do think so
because it takes away black's final idea
of playing f5
um with all that in mind though that's
not what we saw in the game instead we
see
this position appear
um so now with your fabiana caruana you
have
successfully prevented white from
his b3b4 idea that doesn't mean you can
really forget about it though you should
definitely
you know always be aware this
possibility exists
you have improved your position on the
king side by cementing this pawn on g3
and g4 now how do you go about actually
winning the game
well of course we still have this idea
of f5 that we talked about earlier
f5 to change the position and
get at the weaknesses in white's camp so
how do we prepare f5 or is it prepared
enough are we ready to do it what do you
guys think
what do we think
what should black do here just f5
immediately
says bobert
[Music]
ariane says needs more preparation
harry gates thinks we could improve
black's king
rick fade is being suggested rook c5 has
been suggested
b6 first
king of seven king g6
so there are a lot of good ideas and
some not so good ideas
to be honest with you um i think
that the best thing that uh black can do
here
is what fabi does in the game which is
rook c5
you know adding some pressure to this
pawn look forward to c5 by the way
if you go rook a to c5 you're sort of
asking for some trouble with this rook
getting trapped on this square
but yeah rook forward to c5 and the
point is we are applying some pressure
to this pawn why does this matter well
you will see a little bit later on stay
tuned
as for improving the king we're not
really interested
in getting our king to f5 it's more
about getting the king to
f6 allowing some other piece to capture
on f5
like the knight so we can get at this
pawn on g3
get at this rook on e3 and have our king
play a more defensive role defending
this pawn
on f6 so i think the king is well placed
already ready to step
to f6 after the move f5 appears on the
board
as for b6 i think yeah this isn't a bad
move by any means it's definitely
a slight slight improvement to white to
black's position rather
but i just don't think it's the most
useful improvement of all time i think
rook c5 is a bit better
um white actually plays the move bishop
f1 here keeping an eye on b5
because believe it or not you know if
white plays some non shall not move
maybe black was considering to play b5
himself opening up some more
more files on the queen side not
definitely but but maybe it's an idea to
think about
and after bishop f1 we do actually see
the move f5 come on the board
for fabi uh ariantari responds by
capturing if
you don't take this pawn then probably
black is going to do
the capturing for you or at the very
least consider coming to f4
with some very scary looking pawns on
the king's side
so takes was played in the game and now
rook takes d5
is fabi's idea with the pressure on this
pawn becoming very very relevant
and now aryan unfortunately is
losing the thread in the position he
plays the move
rook d3 which is sort of the beginning
of the end
rook d3 is the wrong idea for white i
will tell you so what is the right idea
for white let's see
if we can hold this position against
fabiano caruana
chat room what do you guys think how can
white
still save this game without really even
being worse
at all
and then yeah i'll talk a little bit
more about rook 4 to c5 apparently i did
not do
the best job explaining there
so yeah bobert has the right id again um
rather than
get caught up playing moves like rick d3
trying to trade pieces
white should be playing against the e5
pawn and improving his pieces
so that means rook a to e1 and bishop d3
these two moves are what white should
really be thinking about here
what do these moves have in common they
are stopping the move e4
from being a good idea for 80 e1
e4 bishop g2 and this pawn
is dying um and bishop d3 is probably
even simpler
with the point being you just control
this square outright
uh okay so why is this super super
important
well because in the game we see rook d3
rook c to c5
sorry rook c to c5 network d to c5
rook ad1 and white gets this trade that
he wanted
but now black has the critical idea of
e4
and this is the idea that really gives
black
uh the most winning chances by playing
e4
sort of counter-intuitively again
putting a pawn on a light square
black is effectively shutting this
bishop out of the game and preparing to
invade
with the rook and advances king up the
board king e6 king e5
and now black is definitely the only
person
playing for the advantage in this game
e4 is
sort of the point of fabi's play thus
far and this is why
ariantari would have been better served
putting the rooks in the e file putting
the bishop on d3 earlier
and playing against this idea of e4
so why is rook 4 to c5 so good here
well number one it's pressuring the d5
pawn
and number two really is this subtle
idea of b5 this is why arientari routes
this bishop back
to f1 to keep an eye on the b5 square
because this idea of b5 is sort of a
little bit scary
for white to have to meet with stuff
like knight c4 coming as well and
all of white's queen side pawns falling
under a little bit of pressure
so that's why rook 4 c5 right you want
to pressure d5
and hint at some ideas of b5 and it
induced a slightly weakening move by
arientari to play against it
in the form of bishop f1
um yeah and this is this is mainly the
point here
pressure on this pawn and some ideas of
b5
so in the game we see this position
occur bishop e2
and now the simple move knight takes f5
and fabi is
already sort of just winning notably
white could have
tried to hold on with the move bishop c2
allowing rick takes with check
and now the game is going to be a bit
harder
for fabi to win because
of reasons why is that well this king is
defending the pawn on g3
this knight is not yet really into the
game and white still has
some ideas of pressuring this e pawn a
little bit it's just less
easy for black to advance let's see what
happened in the game though bishop e2
and now the point is if you play some
simple move like rookie one
e3 check is coming king g2 rook d5
and black has just fully taken over at
this point
so in the game aryan switches with his
bishop now to the b5 square
and fabi just comes back to dc knight d6
attacking this bishop again
the bishop comes back to e2 of course
fabi is not going to go for a draw here
and starts advancing the king rook c1
was played
now king e5 work back to d1 and now fabi
uh just continues improving his pieces
he plays rook c7
king g2 we finally get this b6 move that
the chat wanted so badly
and again while this is an improving
move it
it isn't really a move that you play
unless you have nothing else to do
right and defending the a5 pawn isn't
high on your priority list and here
well fabi does have other things to do
the point is aryana's repeating moves he
has nothing better to do so fabian can
take his time here and then
insert a move like b6 bishop a6
is aryan's way of passing now rook f7
bishop back to e2 rook f8 rook b1
now knight f5 again with threats
and b4 by white is finally ariane
playing for some counter play
but knight e3 check comes knight back to
d5 and everything now
is sort of just falling for white the
rook comes over to c8 and the pawn on c3
is indefensible so we see
takes takes in c4 now the knight hops in
to b4 rook b1 the black king invades
and yet i mean the game is just over the
game is just over here
we see fabi go for this winning rook end
game when it is one past pawn against
zero
and aryanthari resigned this position so
i kind of skipped through
once black was just winning there um the
key point in this game
is this sort of battle ideas that we get
from
this position onwards right we see white
hinting at an idea of c3 b4
bobby immediately shuts it down with the
the doubled rooks on the c file
fabi improves his position with g5 g4
and then
the winning position comes after the
complications of
f5 ariane just did not respond correctly
and then fabi was able to win from here
on out
why is this position so good well it's
because
black white is sort of powerless to play
against this pawn from this position
the white king is not going to be
participating in the game
while the black king is and then as we
saw in the game it's just very very easy
for black to invade using the rook
now in the game fabi brought up the to
the f file first
and then eventually invaded on the c
file slash d
file as we saw just improving the pieces
uh playing simple moves while aryan
passes because he has nothing to do
and then after b4 we see fabi
end up on the better side of the
complications right knight d3
and invasions and that's the game
so questions on this end game questions
especially on that battle of ideas
that happened a little bit earlier on
any questions
before we continue
but yeah um i think that is all of
ariantari's losses so far in the
tournament
so apologies to him but like i said he
loses in interesting ways
so i thought those games were all worth
going over
b2 to b4 earlier let me take a quick
look at
b2 to b4 earlier um
well i i guess the question is when
right um if you try to play it anywhere
here
um then then your c pawn just hangs
right fabio was sort of always keeping a
look keeping an eye on this idea
i guess the first possible moment you
could play it is
here you could play b4
but um yeah likely it would just be
similar to what we saw in the game and
actually there's even simpler here with
rook a7
uh b5 is playable but now this bishop is
sort of entombed
right you can just switch sides again
and
black is just winning uh it just doesn't
come with a threat right
and then ariana actually did play it
quite quickly but pressure on the c pawn
was enough
for fabi okay let us move on
up next i wanted to feature a game from
alireza farouja who was actually having
a very decent tournament i think after
today
he has a half point above a level of
course norway does this funny uh scoring
system
where you can gain uh
like three points for a win you get one
point for a draw
and you get one and a half points for
drawing and then winning an armageddon
game
and i think you know
with all of those rules after three
rounds ali reza ferruga somehow is like
five and a half out of ten
although that math doesn't even add up i
i don't know how the scoring system
works
but ellie reza ferrugia with a
technically positive score i believe
after three rounds so let's take a look
at his game
against john kerjerstoff kirschtoff
something like that yanduda the game was
a
con which we can briefly appreciate
before fast forwarding to the end game
shout out to farouja playing the karo
and playing it well by the way i know
this line
pretty well and yeah this move c5 is not
the most common here but
it is apparently playable this move
bishop b3 by the way i i know i'm not
supposed to talk about this stuff
this is probably a little bit wrong uh
just a little bit slow allowing black to
to liquidate some things
um white captured a pawn early on over
here on the b
file we saw knight d5 and you know black
takes in the center
black has some pressure over here in
exchange for his pawn and with this
pressure
we saw a queen trade and after the move
a5 the threat of a4 and capturing uh
on b2 in some manner was too great so we
see
white exchange this rook for this knight
over here on
the uh the c4 square and this is the end
game
that i want to talk about so let's pause
briefly here and talk about what exactly
this material
imbalance is and how the game is going
to continue
so of course first and foremost
black is up the exchange we just saw
white capture on c4
and black capture back due to these
threats uh appearing
on the uh on the b2
pawn so to eliminate those threats white
gives up his rick for a knight
right white in exchange for the moment
has
one pawn uh but of course the story
is not quite that simple because white
has
three pawns on the queen side against
blacks one and black has four pawns on
the king's side
against white's three and actually
in a couple more moves we see white go
bishop d2 rook b5
and take on a5 take on h5 so now the
story is even more complicated
with a strange 4v2 on the king's side
and a 3v0
on the queen side so what do you guys
think about this
end game is black better because rooks
are good and knights are bad
is white actually doing okay because
these three pawns have nothing in their
way to stop them from victory
what should be going on here chess king
likes black
he prescribes to the methodology of the
rook being worth five points and knights
being worth three points perhaps
[Music]
not a bad methodology at all
bobert likes black peter peterson likes
white
george offers no definitive opinion but
he does say that white is more
mobile marty says equal maddie rather i
don't know
i can't say names um and yeah
the the truth of the matter is nobody's
really sure what's going on in this end
game
uh the the engine included if you ask
the computer
it'll give you some score like minus one
minus 1.5
but that's the score that it gives when
it sees that black is up in exchange
and isn't really sure what's going on
right at a certain point in these end
games when you ask the computer the
evaluation
and it gives you like minus one that
means i have no idea what's going on
rook is worth five knight is worth three
white has a pawn for it
plus one for black right uh and so maybe
i think that this end game
should with really really good play uh
end up in a draw
uh why do i think that well because if
white plays very accurately
on the defensive side of things white
might be able to actually stop these
four pawns on the
king side for ferugia and that means
that black is then going to have to
switch to
to a defensive roll stopping the three
pawns on the queen side of the board
now is black ever going to lose this end
game probably not the rooks are good
enough
that the three pawns on the queen's side
shouldn't really create too much
of a substantial threat with good play
of course practically you know if if i
had either side in this position
i would lose instantly against a player
like ferruja or duda
but that's not what's at stake here
right
um in the game uh duda starts with the
move
rook g1 which is a pretty interesting
move i'm
i definitely think this is not what
would come to mind
for most people at first thought moving
the work from c1
to g1 so what is the point well the
point is
duda is anticipating that ferruja is
going to try to make a past pawn on the
king's side
how's fruition going to try to make that
past pawn well it seems like the easiest
way
might not be by playing something like
f5 e5
e4 in these end games the past pawn
that's the most valuable
is usually the one that's on the side of
the board the one that's away from
white's king
that's actually away from white's knight
that's the pawn that's going to be most
difficult to stop
so duda is likely anticipating moves
like g5
h5 g4 and going for this move
h3 so all the way from here
duda is perhaps thinking about you know
having to defend
this g pawn and also potentially having
the capture on the h3 square
in addition to that this move does a
very nice thing which is
vacate the c1 square and the c1 square
is going to be useful
for the knight to reroute either to e2
or out to d3
uh so rook g1 that's sort of the story
behind this move
black now actually starts with the move
rook b5 which makes a ton of sense he
needs to get out of the way
of these pawns in order to push them
white plays the move bishop d2
sort of solidifying his pieces here this
bishop was a bit loose on a5 under
pressure
and now of course the time is right for
ferugia
to push when you're playing these
positions with pawns on both sides of
the board
you sort of want to be pushing as fast
as possible
it is very much going to be a race
between whose pawns can get there
first and so for ruja gets a head start
in this case
by pushing the pawn to h5
white now is forced to spend a couple
tempi solidifying his position
because right now of course it's
difficult to push these pawns when the
b2 pawn
is under so much pressure and this
knight is also in the way
that's why we see c3 by white
alireza has no reason not to push king
c2 by white again solidifying unpinning
and alireza again has no reason not to
push
and now knight c1 getting out of the way
of the pawns and again preparing to
reroute the knight
to the king's side now i would like to
ask you guys in the chat room
what do you think the best continuation
is here
for uh farouja
obviously we want to make a past pawn
somehow on the king's side of the board
but the specifics of that can get rather
messy
so what's the best way to continue now
for farouja
so there are two competing uh ideas in
the chat room already
one is g3 and one is g takes f
okay h4 has also been suggested which is
a
you know sort of sacrifice of the pawn
not real not a real sacrifice because
the pawn is defended but
in a sense it is sacrificial in nature
a lot of people say g3 and onlyek says
he believes he played g3 but he's not
sure why
and yeah g3 is the move played in the
game and this is a pretty interesting
one
i don't actually think g3 was quite
correct because white was able to set up
a very
you know sort of unique interesting type
of fortress
i think the best move in this case is to
immediately create a past pawn which you
can do
in fact by playing g takes f what's the
downside well the downside is you lose
some time by getting checked you have to
put the king on a slightly awkward
square
like h7 the upside is that there are
zero things standing in between this
pawn and becoming a queen
on h1 it is a past pawn through and
through
and with that i think black has very
very good winning chances here
um for example if something like f4
trying to interfere with the pieces here
we can push to h4 without concern
knight d3 now this rook is sort of in
danger of getting trapped so rook a4
hits this guy a3 rook h5
works rooks belong behind rooks belong
behind
past pawns and just for example here
something like knight f2 and
the story is very much going to be about
this pawn on
h4 can we push to h3 uh maybe that's a
bit premature
because this guy could be falling but i
think
we can just sort of reroute with
something like hate
black white should try to blockade and
something like rick g i think is even
perfectly fine here for black although
maybe richie it's not not the best
these positions are always incredibly
complicated the point is
black has a past pawn on h4 is it enough
to objectively win the game against
perfect play
i don't know but it is a past pawn
nonetheless
in addition to that black is going to
have ideas of playing e5 a little bit
later on
creating a second passed pawn for
himself as well
and i think this would have offered
maybe better winning chances than what
furuja got
in the game that being said ferruja did
in fact win the game
so let's go back to what he played there
is a third option in the position by the
way
which is something that i think bobert
was mentioning which is you know not
doing anything with this pawn
and just playing something like king f8
and i think this isn't bad but i do
think it is a bit slow
moves like b3 can come and something
like fg4
after this rook moves and uh you might
have a hard time creating past pawn
after fghg appears on the board
um same thing with h4 i think here the
move b3
is the reason why this this isn't going
to be so good because then f takes g4 is
an
actual pawn sacrifice for the moment in
the game though we see g3 which is a
very
interesting change in position now of
course the idea is still
h4 h3 but the difference is now the g
pawn is going to become
past and not the h pawn there because of
course g takes h is always going to be
playable
for white so how does white respond to
this well he starts by pushing his own
pawns which is very very reasonable
b3 rook c8 duda goes a4
rook f5 is uh ferrous choice
now knight e2 hits this pawn on
g3 so h4 appears and now we see c4
by duda and you know it's sort of a
warning to a black here it's
like yeah great job pushing your h g
pawns but be careful buddy i have
three connected passers on the queen
side of the board best of luck to you
so uh now if you are for ruja
you need to find some way to continue
this game
right for the moment your g and h pawns
are sort of locked down there's no way
to advance those guys any further so how
do you continue the game here
what's the plan for black
if black captures white doesn't have to
capture white kind of has to capture
that pawn on f3
otherwise that pawn is going to be a bit
strong
danilo wants to reroute the rooks to the
h and g
files and that's a pretty interesting
idea i don't think it's going to be
the best idea in this case why not
well if you completely abandon the queen
side and just sort of go rook h5
king h7 rook g8 these guys might start
pushing
they might start pushing up the board
right so
i think you know black is a pretty good
defensive setup actually against these
pawns b4 is hard to play without hanging
the c4 pawn
a5 might be playable but it's going to
be a bit lonely there without you know
b4 being playable
c5 of course is being well prevented for
the moment so
i sort of like how black has his
position set up
over here um i think the way to continue
is an idea that nobody has
actually mentioned yet i don't think
it's rook d8
bishop d4 again i like where these rooks
are preventing b4 for the moment kind of
preventing a5 with ideas of bishop d8
when b4 again
is unplayable i think the idea is to
break down
this guy on f3 that's why furuja plays
the move e5
and i sort of like this for black in a
practical sense
the idea is to go e4 and just either
get the rook in the game or take on f3
and b
be sort of crushing uh white goes bishop
e3
in this case maybe preparing something
like c5
and we see bishop g5 now by black taking
away
the dark squared bishop for white which
was using which was doing a nice
offensive job preparing c5 a nice
defensive job as well
guarding these important squares so
bishop g5 rick g5 played in the game
rook h1 is how duda is getting counter
play against the h pawn
and now we see rook h5 king c3
so white is slowly but surely preparing
to advance up the board over here
but now with the position simplified a
little bit
the way is sort of clear for f5 right
duda did a great job of playing against
the immediate e4 by playing uh this
bishop e3 idea
but now uh black is able to sort of
advance with this
f pawn by the way be careful here if you
play something like knight takes g3
thinking you have a very clever tactic
you might be running into
rook takes g2 rook takes h4
rook f2 when at the end of the day
you might not be so happy about the
pawns you captured because your rook is
sort of entombed
your rook actually is sort of entombed
all right sorry not your rook your
knight is sort of entombed
and you're going to have a very
difficult time sort of untangling in
this position
so no knight takes g3 played by duda
instead
b4 which i think is along the right
track just
strictly going for counter play by
pushing these pawns on the queen side
now f4 by furuja takes away even this
option
of capturing on g3
a5 now by white is actually the losing
move
um so black to play or sorry
white to play and draw this position
what do you guys think white to play and
draw
i will be very impressed if anybody can
come up with a move
very very impressed if you guys can come
up with white to play
and draw here
michael harmon says b5
knight b1 has been suggested which
is not a legal move but then this is
amended to say knight
g1 and yeah the answer here i think the
simplest way to draw
is actually the very counter-intuitive
knight g1
putting the knight in the rook on the
starting squares you know of course
what else preparing for the next game as
ben feingold would say
what's the point the point is that these
are the two squares
that black absolutely must pass through
if he is going to create a past pawn
and with the knight on g1 black can't
break through
you just cannot break through these two
squares no matter how hard you try
if you play something like e4 it will be
captured
and the idea here is not to play knight
f3 or knight h3
it's to leave the knight on g1 and say
yeah you are not going to break
through this uh light squared blockade
that i have
created you can go something like rookie
5
network f5 but rook e5 you'll be met by
king d4
not king d3 but king d4 if you step back
now that you've released the tension on
h3
knight f3 can be played and once again
white
has successfully blockaded these king
side pawns
and this was the idea that was missed by
yon duda
apparently b5 is also potentially
playable but i really don't understand
why to be honest with you
maybe we can compare this with what
happened in the game and arrive at some
sort of conclusion
apparently h3 is the idea rick h3
rick h3 gh3
and then if e4
yeah maybe this is still losing knight
g1 here
yeah i have no idea why this is
different than the game to be honest why
a5 and b5 have many meaningful
differences
let's take a look at what happened in
the game and find out so a5 played in
the game and then as i sort of spoiled
the idea is h3 here breaking through now
and creating past pawns
g takes h3 and now e4 and
uh these pawns are sort of unstoppable
no time for knight takes f4 by the way
not actually because of
ef3 when black white can actually
capture this guy because this move is
check
but rather because of the move rook f5
right
the knight moves away and we capture
here and now black gets the same stuff
but without losing a rook alternatively
you know of course
white is perfectly you know allowed to
go for this position
with one full rook down but being down
one full rook
is going to be tough even with four
pawns to uh to compensate here
um in the game after e4 uh f takes e4
was played and i think this is
uh you know sort of the dead lost move
rook f1 was actually playable when after
g2 rook f2
e takes f3 knight g1 is still
some sort of blockade obviously a worse
blockade than the one that we had
earlier
but this might keep the game going
fortunately rookie 5 rookie 3 is going
to be pretty powerful for black
but that's not what we see in the game
in the game we saw f takes e4 and now g2
takes with check f3 and the game ended
pretty shortly here
after f2 when yon went ahead and
resigned
so what's the big deal though there's
still this mystery which i didn't even
realize i thought knight g1 was like the
drawing move
apparently b5 is okay so what's the
difference here why does rook take ch3
lose in this case wow apparently rook a8
is the only move to win the game here
this is one that's beyond me my friends
this is one that's beyond me the same
idea
is drawing for the same reasons of
knight g1
as b5 but yeah apparently
uh you go rook a8 and you win the game
yeah that's a bit of a stunner to me i
guess the idea
is that after a5 rook a8 these puns are
actually impossible to move
right if you had the pawn on b5 and rook
a8 was played king b4 could be played
but now these pawns just cannot move and
so
white is welcome to bring his king back
to the king's side
but now black is able to uh to activate
his own king here
and if something like c5 trying to
advance the pawns
looks like just king f7 king c4 king e6
king b5 and now it's it's too little too
late
uh apparently that's that's a bit of a
stunner to me so apparently
if white had played b5 this position
is drawing because king b4 is playable
after rook a8
with stuff like c5 and these pawns are
actually useful
for white did not realize that was a
drawing idea when i prepped this lecture
i thought this idea of knight g1 was
sort of the only way to play
but apparently this is tactically okay
for white as well although even even
better than king b4
is is b6 here when you can't take this
because of b7 so
wow stunning idea there that i did not
realize while i was doing the lecture
prep
so this was a very very complicated end
game but do you guys have
questions on how this was played and why
uh why black ended up winning
any questions on this one obviously this
one is rather complicated
but at its core the ideas for black
where he was uh the ideas were number
one
position the rooks so that these queen
side pawns can't advance too rapidly
and number two just clown push on the
king's side
and try to create some kind of past pawn
over there at the end of the game
uh furuja does end up winning thanks to
this idea
but duda did have his counter chances to
uh to draw
what's the valuation in this position so
if you ask the engine it says -1 here
which means it it doesn't know it sees
that black is up in exchange for a pawn
and spits out minus one um
looking at the game more i think it's
possible that it's winning for black
but i think it's maybe even more likely
that white can draw this
with hyper accurate play practically
though it's going to be a difficult game
for white to be sure
okay if there are no questions
on this one i think i have time to very
very briefly
show you guys one more end game we only
have 10 minutes left in the lecture so
it's more just going to be
of ex you know exposing you guys to the
game
rather than going in depth into the
ideas but let's take a look
all right and our last game is again
going to be a game of dudas
and much like aryantari he is having a
pretty tough tournament but he keeps
losing in interesting ways
so let's see how his game actually goes
here against
uh levon aronian so don't care about any
of this
that's not an endgame oh wait we arrived
at the end game rather quickly of course
duda playing a pretty quiet line here
going for an early queen trade
and then we see some pieces coming off
the board bishop f4
king f4 rook 88 bishop b6 and fe 6.
so you might be looking at this game you
might be
saying this is the most boring game of
chess i have ever seen in my life
they traded off all the pieces besides
the rooks the pieces
most well known for you know drawing
every end game that they
they are ever in and then uh then they
played this position but
plenty of things to take away from this
end game this is sort of chess
at its most base level at its most pure
there are only two rooks for either side
there's one
imbalance in the position and it looks
to be unfavorable for black
so how on earth does levon aronian end
up winning this game
well let me show you guys duda starts
with rookie 2 we see rook d4
check king g3 or hd8 taking over the
open file
in the meantime duda goes for rook a to
e1 now i should say
if all duda wanted was a draw rook a to
d1 is the way to do it
now black is never taking over the open
file
so duda is actually playing for more
with rookie 2 and rook a to e1
playing for pressure against the e pawn
but allowing black some control over the
d
file uh levonironian controls the e pawn
like this
and white goes f4 a pretty natural idea
actually to control the e5 square
and make sure that the e pawn stays
firmly put the game continues with king
f6 king of three both sides improving
their kings
and we see now aronian play h5 and i
think this is the first
really instructive move that levon plays
the point is
white can now never play g4 and after
white solidifies his position with g3
as we'll see a great way to play against
the structure of the pawns
by the way a couple more moves being
played here is to have the idea of
h4 in your back pocket this is a
fantastic way
for levon to play against these uh
sort of three pawns in a nice little
chain here by playing h4 when g takes h
would fracture the structure
g4 would weaken this pawn on f4
and ignoring it may allow this pawn to
step to h3
when it is dangerously close to queening
and introduces
all sorts of tactics for black so now
obviously h4 is not going to immediately
be played but levon has this idea in his
back pocket here and it's a good one
at that g6 played first
we see rookie 5 b6 b3 c5
c4 and now instructive idea number two
we saw levon go for some ideas of this
on the king's side
and now even in the symmetrical position
uh notably
this pawn on b6 is about as safe as it
can get
whereas this pawn on b3 is not as safe
it's a little bit more open
with black having access to it along
this open file
so levon plays a5 and sort of dares duda
to go for
a symmetrical uh structure over here
when access to this b3 pawn may become
very very important
king f2 played instead the players do
lavon goes rook d3 further introducing
ideas now of a4
and preventing white from playing a4
duda takes back control of this third
rank and levon trades off one set of
rooks
we see a check and rook d1
duda goes king f3 and at this point
levon
plays the interesting move pawn to a4
and this is how levon
really starts to make something out of
nothing here
his weakness on e6 is sort of never
really going to be felt anymore with
only one rook on the board and the black
king well place to defend it
and now he is inciting weaknesses in the
uh in the white camp here duda tried b
takes a4 but now after rook uh c1
white is quite simply unable to defend
all of his pawns
we see rookie three played in the game
rick takes c4
rook a3 king f5 now advancing the pawns
and dude's idea was not a bad one his
idea was to play a5 here to get rid of
these this b pawn for this a pawn
b5 would be ill-advised when this pawn
runs very very fast so b
takes a5 rook takes a5 is played
now is black winning this end game
absolutely not is black better in this
end game
practically i would say definitely yes
why is that well for one his pawn is
slightly more advanced
and secondly his king is much better
placed than his opponent's king
by virtue of having this pawn on e6
rather than f5
his king was able to occupy the f5
square and now after rook c3 check
king e2 lavon has a very nice idea to
firmly seize the advantage in this
endgame
so what you guys got for me here
black to move with a very interesting
idea to seize the advantage
rick d3 seems strange why not work b2
i'll take a look at that at the very end
but we are sort of rushing here just
wanted to show you guys this last game
while we had the time and yeah the chat
room is on it tonight
this idea of h4 finally comes into play
uh
breaking down this f4 pawn and
by the way don't even think about
ignoring it with something like a4
although maybe you can think about
ignoring it but these ideas are still
going to be in the position
as well as some ideas of doing this and
going for a good old-fashioned 2v1 end
game even if it is technically drawn
ok in the game though do that actually
captures again
and in this case i think this gives
black some more practical tries
because now the king is able to invade
on f4
king d2 played in the game now rook h3
we do see this pawn fall off the board
but we see rick takes h2 and now e5
notably uh levon ironian not actually
capturing on a2 directly
but understanding that his advantage is
this e pawn he's going to win by
promoting this guy
and so he starts pushing him right away
when pushing this guy is sort of a lost
cause
well i can always get behind this pawn
so rookie c4 check was played
by duda and this is a bit of a mistake
inducing e4
is not really what is uh going to help
him in this position black was pushing
this pawn anyways
rick back to c6 now challenges this pawn
but king f3 is a nice winning move
by lavon ronian what's the point the
point is this king cannot stay
in front of the pawn any longer rick f6
check means king
d6 now king f1 is rook h1 check
the king has been evicted lavon picks up
this pawn as well
goes king e2 and this is winning
um rick h7 by the way is a miracle draw
somehow for duda here apparently rook h5
was the winning move why well after rook
h7
apparently a4 is playable e3 means
a5 and no matter how you try to push
this
pawn a6 is coming e2 now rook
e6 and what's the point the point is
king d2
well sorry the point is you have to play
rook f7 first to cut off this
king then after king g2 if you try to
promote this pawn there's rick d6 check
and you can't escape the checks and if
you try to build a bridge as we've all
been taught
of course a7 is just in time for
uh white for okay five there's rookie
seven
and again you are unable to build the
bridge thanks to the threats
of this a pawn for example king
uh to e4 rookie five but at the end of
the day
it's actually going to be white who's
winning this game thanks to a nice
little tactic here
with queen e8 so that was somehow a
miracle draw for white that i wanted to
just point out
so people didn't yell at me rook h5 was
winning because then that pawn can never
get past a5
but this was missed in the game both
players and a bit of well one player and
a bit of time pressure here levon
iranian with over an hour on his clock
versus seven minutes
and duda played the move rook b6 instead
which does lose
to the simple push um
pretty nice idea here by levon going
king of c2 highlighting the fact that
the rook could not get far enough away
to give meaningful checks from the side
and now rook f7 cuts off this king and
this a pawn is far too slow rook f5 is
played in the game
the point is now if a5 rook takes a5
with queens
or k2 check played king d3 rook a1 king
e3
check king e4 rook a1 and then the final
move of the game
is the nice rook d5 with rook d one to
follow
uh sort of unstoppable uh promotion of
the pawn
key one means king e3 and again rook d1
will be coming
so a nice game by levon aronian winning
from a
seemingly dead equal position the key
points i want to highlight
are this a4 and h4 brakes now there was
a quick question
why rookie 3 why not rook b2 to be
honest with you rook b2 was probably
just a better move
i'm not sure why rookie 3 was played
maybe duda had
had some idea in mind that i wasn't
thinking of but
one notable fact is that after this
variation
the a2 pawn would be attacked whereas in
the variation played in the game
the rook is already on a5 defending this
guy but to be honest it doesn't make too
much of a difference
in the game the key mistake here i think
was allowing this king to get to f3 like
this
i think rook c4check in particular it's
also pretty wrong
um all right thank you guys so much for
joining me here tonight i know we didn't
spend a lot of time on that last end
game
but i thought it was worth showing with
these neat little h4a4 pushes on both
sides of the board
that lavonna ronin pulled out to win a
nice end game against dion
duda hopefully you enjoyed tonight's
lecture on all these various end games
from norway chess i think
this is a really interesting tournament
so far it's been a lot of fun to follow
hopefully you guys are enjoying it as
well if you're watching live the fun is
going to continue
on our twitch channel with analyze your
games if you're watching the youtube
version
that's it for me tonight again thank you
so much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you